good to see was shot Jennings how are
you sir pleasure pleasure what are you
doing in Los Angeles you're doing
something with the deep with the dancing
before before they I did in the page on
season 24 I did stop by for a little
guest surprise surprise my partner Emma
Slater she's amazing
what's your the bestest season but now I
stopped by but I'm out here on a couple
different projects one that I can't talk
about yet but it's not like Fight Club
is that what you're saying okay but I
you know LA nights I've been spending a
lot of time out here lately I got a
trainer out here so when I back on my
train all morning and take care of the
business I'm working on during the
evening now I know you what you told me
backstage that you are training as if
the phone rings you can go and suit up
pad up put on a helmet and get on the
field right now for a team in the
National Football League absolutely a
team called me today I'm ready to
practice the next okay and so how close
do you think that might be to a
possibility
you know having a couple conversations
with a few teams you know you never know
when the triggers gonna pull it I mean
obviously planned planning to leave for
for for sometime is it's basically
always uncertainty and so the best thing
you can do is be ready and think when
when opportunity presents itself is too
late to prepare for it so I'm gonna be
ready no matter how old are you 32
okay 32 32 now why do you think NFL
teams when somebody at your position
hits 28 29 30 says okay let's just go
back to the draft and get another
running back for our system it's a
couple of different reasons I mean
obviously they're they're traditional
wear and tear there's also a financial
reason behind that some teams may not
want to invest but I think I think one
thing that people forget or don't
analyze or give consideration to is if a
player knows how to take care of their
body for myself I feel like I've been
able to reverse you know the older I get
the smarter I get the more in shape I am
you know I eat I eat I'm gluten and
dairy free and I sleep in a hyperbaric
oxygen chamber which rejuvenates my body
so I feel like I've been playing Reverse
I've been able to allow my body to catch
up with my maturity mentally
so for what do you mean you sleep in a
chamber I mean how big is this chamber
the chamber is about nine by five all
right and it's it's it's it's let's say
it's a it compresses 4.1 monster set to
4.1 psi
500 2025 atmosphere all that fancy stuff
to say below 15 feet sea level of
pressure so but for just pedestrian
people like myself who sleep in the open
air
yeah is that like a queen-size bed what
do we got is that a queen-size
California king okay it's it's it's
smaller than a single yeah it's it's
pretty small but it's it's his own
purpose like this is the first thing I
bested in in my life
when I went to the NFL in buy a car
anything I got made fun of I drove the
same car from high school I said I was
gonna rotted - the wheels fell off in
funny story I was driving to pick up
somebody did her board we literally did
fall off the car you said you cannot
make this story I literally it fell off
the person I was picking up it was a
girlfriend at my time she she didn't
find it funny because I was late but I
vested in a hyperbaric oxygen chamber
because I didn't understand the stock
market I didn't know how money how money
operated so I figured I can invest in
myself because I could measure how hard
I work and I bought a chamber Rashad
Jennings here on the Rich Eisen show can
we put the entire Giants team inside
this chamber to improve it right now
what do you think you can you definitely
can everybody needs everybody needs to
go in that chamber at Owen - when you
first got to the Giants in 2014 fresh
off a very good season for you in
Oakland in 2013 Ben McAdoo arrived on
the staff just when you arrived is that
is that the case
exactly yeah he came in offensive
coordinator now when you saw him first
met him saw him go through everything
did you say this is head coaching
material in the NFL you know when I saw
him I didn't you know obviously getting
accustomed to the whole entire
organization that wasn't something on
the forefront of my mind but I can
definitely see why he was a candidate to
be a head coach line fo he has he has a
certain pores about him and one thing
that I like to tell people especially
that never play football especially in
the NFL when you're speaking in front of
53 plus a grown man with
it's there they're professionals the
best of what they do your voice does
have to carry in a room where people
respect you
and are willing to respond and that was
one thing as the offensive coordinator I
noticed he always had and he's
definitely done it as a head coach when
I was there well after the loss on
Monday Night Football and he's like I'll
put this one on me
I did hear in the locker room afterwards
hey it's all on us in here so whatever
he told the team that when they went in
front of the cameras and the media they
were lockstep in they weren't pointing
fingers for instance and I when when
players point fingers I always think the
coach doesn't have a firm grasp on what
the heck's going on in his locker room
all that said he threw Eli under the bus
about that fourth and goal where there
was a delay of game penalty on Eli on
Monday Night Football and basically
calling a sloppy quarterback clay Eli
said hey you know what I don't mind
being coached you people can be too
sensitive here do you think that the
Giants at Owen two have what it takes in
that locker room to turn things around
in 2017 absolutely I said beside Eli
Manning I like him beside him for three
years and so I got to know this guy on a
personal level and there's no doubt
about it I mean when you have him on the
center and you have the type of quality
and iron that he has in the poise you
got the right guy and no doubts who from
from top to bottom the Giants
organization is is definitely equality
and I feel like they're gonna have a
turnaround there's no question about
that but as far as the Eli saying that
I'm coachable he is and Eli's the type
of God is always going to put the
successes to the team and the blame for
losing on him and so as so as coached by
McAdoo so you know to see them to kind
of have that conversation it doesn't
surprise is the often simple simple to
simple though Rashad that it's they run
you know 31 personnel pretty much damn
near 100% of the time and when clearly
the protections breaking down McAdoo's
not calling a quick game there's no one
there to chip
there's no fullback which is odd for a
Giants offense do you think
based on you know what you've known and
what you see that the Giants offense is
advanced enough in 2017 to win football
games well I believe is advanced enough
because they got especially what I look
at on the roster now from what when I
was there they did add a fullback back
in the roster which we did we played the
whole entire season last year with
father fullback I think we had one snap
where we put offensive lineman there so
it does that does take an element away
from the game where the defensive
coordinator doesn't have to address or
prepare for it throughout the course of
the week but the weapons that they have
on their team the game protection week
to week and I'm setting I'm going to I'm
setting down it's obviously I know the
offense inside and out yes so I'm
watching the game and I'm calling other
protections I'm calling out everything
as I see the game progression there's no
doubt it's just one it's always just one
little thing that could turn the whole
entire game around they have one of the
best defenses in the league they're
gonna continue to sprout they're gonna
the defensive side I know those guys in
the locker room they're gonna put the
ownership on them the offense is gonna
get together I have I have pretty I have
confidence that they could turn it
around over there Kyle started oh it's
okay
a couple more minutes with Rashad
Jennings here in the Rich Eisen show
would you think of what Todd Gurley
cooked up last night I've been cooking
up first three weeks this season yeah he
look he looks he looks like his his
first year and the league again
he's one of he's one of the free players
in the league if you ask me I think he
has a specific skill that's it's it's
uncompelled he to make people miss jump
over people catch out the backfield he's
a loose if he's strong balanced he can
do he can do everything he can block I
mean I think somebody with the ability
to block and that's something always
prior to myself for him protecting the
quarterback not dropping the football
and you know last year I did I didn't
fumble one time and I always protected a
quarterback never gave up a set and so
that's something that he can do and he
can catch it so it's not one flaw in his
game other than giving the ball more so
who is the most strict
Tom Coughlin's or Bergeron shot Jennings
which one who's the stricter who's the
stricter tum tugger Iran does Bergeron
lay down the law if you're not out there
on the dance floor five minutes before
you're supposed to be out on the dance
floor I mean you're in trouble you get a
fine
I'm Dancing with the Stars I'm gonna say
I'm gonna go with Tom Coughlin okay Tom
Coughlin Coughlin Coach Coughlin because
he has we Burge doesn't have his own
time
there's no Bergeron Tom no no this
doesn't none of that Coughlin has his
own time that people have to respect in
the building I mean when you can make a
whole entire organization change their
clock five minutes ahead and you live
like that I mean it's it's that's a
staple to who you are so I definitely
give it up I mean the Jaguars hitting
people in the mouth it does look like a
Coughlin old school as opposed to the
one that kind of morphed into a pass
first offense
yeah in New York they're mauling people
they plan they like to run the ball they
got a full bag out there
smashed mouths and in his fun I'm happy
for Coach Coughlin you know getting a
chance to play under the leadership of a
Hall of Famer and soon to be we all know
that and for him to go back to
Jacksonville you know I know he's he got
the that big old smile I can see him
right now and then on that golf course
so I and then you're your life I mean
Dancing with the Stars how big was that
for you Rashad and you're in your life
and your progression and as a running
back to something more as huge as that's
been a real highlight in a very neat
experience to do Dancing with the Stars
I'm a type of person every single
offseason I pick up a new type of craft
okay I always do that just keep my mom
moving one offseason I learn magic
tricks so I know a bunch of magic tricks
the next offseason pick up guitar never
put it down the next season archery next
season poetry fencing dance this is how
I dance was on my list I'm done in
Florida I trained there every offseason
I signed up for a proper ballroom dance
I never danced before down my life
properly I go to club eight but I'm
never properly danced so I signed up for
dance class yeah
I was gonna do it a week later because I
had some things going on and then I get
a call after signing up three days later
about the answer with the stars so I got
to learn how to dance it was just that
the whole entire nation that watch
Dancing with the Stars I was under a
microscope so it was fun I got to know
myself on a different level
I enjoyed dance there's something
special about ballroom dance and I wish
I was introduced to it younger for so
many different reasons but I tell you
what it's unfortunate because now if I'm
in the best shape of my life like dance
forces you to use your core and yes you
didn't know it forces you to work that
polar opposite side of your muscles than
football forces you so I feel like I'm
so balanced right now no I know that
about dance certainly when I do the
overbite
good to see you Rashad Jennings here on
the show season 25 of Dancing with the
Stars the nice little guest appearance
for you you've got a book coming out
next year we look forward to that and
everything else that's going on with
your with your foundation everybody can
follow at at Rashad Jennings on Twitter
or Rashad Jennings foundation com good
to see you sir
pleasure the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint